what's the next term in the following
sequence it goes 1 4 8 48 88 488 what's
the next term which actually is very
easy and why that's not so obvious well
it's a little strange for 8 48 88 for 8
8 and obviously the next one is going to
be 8 8 8 and then for 8 8 8 the right
way to look at this is to stare at these
numbers look at this number what do you
see well you see 8 but more important
you see 2 holds when you look at 48 you
see 3 holes
88 has four holes in it for has one hole
if you draw if was that way and one has
no holes in it so the definition of this
sequence is it's the smallest positive
number that has n holes in it people
always get really funny about sequences
and numbers that are sort of based n
specific this is this is how you draw
your numbers specifically if you draw
your for non enclosed it would be it
would change the sequence in that case
if your 4 is non enclosed then you would
make it one six eight sixty eight eighty
eight six eight eight and so on and if
you'd do your twos in a very fancy way
with a hole in them then the six could
be replaced by a two this is topology um
what we're doing is partitioning the
piece of paper in two parts with it
using numbers so if you write down a
four you've partitioned the plane into
two parts this part and the outside so
it's topology
this one is another base-10 sequence so
but it's lovely 60 120 180 240 3 3 and
the question is what comes next
don't get distracted into looking for
something that's too complicated
[Music]
watch carefully there's nothing up my
sleeve I'm just gonna move the comma
then I'm gonna move that color and that
color and that comma and there's an
invisible zero and so the next one get
it 6 12 18 24 30 36 so that one after
that would be 42 their multiples of 6
nothing could be simpler but if you were
misled into looking for something
complicated you wouldn't get that is
sneaky that one yeah yeah yeah yeah I
like it
it's misleading its deceptive sleight of
hand 1 we get 0 2 we get 0 3 we get 0 4
we get 0
hmm this doesn't look too promising all
right this is ever gonna get more than 0
yet 5 we get 4 6 we get 9 7 you get 5 8
you get 1 9 we get 110 I'll do a couple
more to make it 10 we get 0 11 you'll
never guess what we get for 1155 what's
the rule
[Music]
let me show you the answer I put those
squares on top of the numbers and you
look through the window you have to
think like a Roman v IV for high hex 9 v
5 8 1 there's a single 1 9 1 10 is
nothing 11 is 55 and so on
like that would have taken me a year so
of course it might not be a legal Roman
number you might have the ones and the
V's and the MS in the wrong order in
which case the way the sequence would be
defined as you say that's zero for that
term two closely related sequences in
the sense that they both have names they
both have slightly misleading names
titles and the first one are the even
numbers well you know what the even
numbers are 2 4 6 8 but I would like you
to figure out what the even numbers are
to know I have to be very careful 4 6 7
7 is not even 8 9 10 11
it's the next even number and then 32 34
36 40 42 44 50 52 54 56 are you getting
the idea 16 let me continue 62 64 66 mm
those are the even numbers why are those
the even numbers
[Music]
what do you notice about these numbers
for one thing they're all even the
second thing is that if you say if you
write out them the number in English
there are no E's in them one is missing
because one has an e in it three has an
e in it eight has an e in it in fact
there's a theorem it's an old theorem of
mine every hard number contains an e and
you can easily prove that by looking at
all the odd numbers and check why they
called even numbers E is banned any
other questions let me show you another
one with a name these are the emotes and
again the name is a hint in in this case
it's actually a legitimate hint the maps
as you might guess well let me show you
what they look like first of all and
then you can guess 13 17 then it's not
19 you might have thought it I'm just
gonna write 19 but it's actually um 31
37 71 and that's probably enough of a
hint
[Music]
well obviously they're primes and if you
look at the name you see it's Prime
backwards so these are the primes which
when you read them backwards are still
Prime's but different primes so we don't
put down 11 because it's palindromic
these are Prime's which when you read it
backwards gives you a different prime I
know what you're all thinking everyone
what is the largest known Emer as far as
I can tell it's this or its decimal
expansion is this now if you like these
fun little puzzles I've actually got one
left over one that got cut from this
video but it's still pretty good fun
I've put it over on the numberphile 2
channel there's links on the screen and
in the description and we'll have Neil
Sloan back really soon talking about
more amazing sequences from his online
encyclopedia stay tuned for that